schoenberg bonjour merci de répondre à
nos questions aujourd'hui sur arte
france la russie répondra de manière
militaire et technique aux menaces
occidentales à quoi le président russe
fait-il allusion le dossier ukrainien je
suppose et comment est-ce qu'il faut
interpréter cette déclaration bon
d'abord il l'a dit le 21 décembre 6h 30
30 ans jour pour jour après la
dissolution de lure ce qui est quand
même une plaie qui a laissé des traces
donc devant l'ensemble des militaires il
y avait une espèce de dramatisation et
en même temps un lien historique avec
tout ce qui s'est passé alors
effectivement il ya ce qu'on peut
appeler en termes diplomatiques un
espèce de jambes team sert à rien
jusqu'à présent on parlait de l'ukraine
on parlait de formats de normandie et
puis on a on a effectivement selon les
renseignements occidentaux des troupes
russes qui s'approche quelle frontière
ukrainienne demi kilomètre et vladimir
poutine
hamas et finalement c'est tout pour se
faire entendre et ouvrir un dialogue il
l'a fait d'une manière aux yeux
l'élection tour brutal mais il dit
toujours six mois j'ose paletot on
écoute pas on négocie pas avec moi et
maintenant sur le problème ukrainien
s'est dressée effectivement l'ensemble
de ce qu'on appelle la stratégie
larchitecture de de sécurité stratégique
là où la lumière poutine veut obtenir
trois assurances et correspondant l'a
très bien montré d'abord il veut il veut
aboutir à deux traits pts et des traités
obligatoire il a dit les états unis
sortent toujours des prêtés maintenant
il faut mettre ça sur papier il faut que
ça soit obligatoire un traité entre les
états unis et la russie qui est qui et
des garanties et un traité entre l'otan
et la russie donc ça c'est les textes et
le contenu ses preuves 1 pas d'extension
de la de l'otan en dehors de ce qui a
été fait en 97 donc pas question aux
yeux de moscou que l'ukraine ou la
géorgie un tag l'otan
deuxième pas de bases militaires les
bases militaires et même pas d'armement
nouveau on gèle ce qui existe et
troisième chose on empêche le
développement d'une coopération
militaire sauf cas exceptionnel il
serait sous la réserve d'une acceptation
russe donc voilà une position de
négociation
j'allais dire très forte très dur mais
comme toujours on met le maximum sont à
table pour entrer dans une discussion
normalement si on en croit la réponse du
porte-parole du département de la maison
blanche états unis cette semaine même
avant d'oise vont répondre à la russie
en en mettant en avant ce qu'on appelle
le format approprié est ce que ça sera
une négociation moscou washington comme
ça a été pendant les années 70 80 ou
c'est ce sera élargi un groupe de
puissances alors comme il ya deux volets
on sait très bien quel format de
normandie c'est à dire les cartes russie
ukraine rousset france des grands et et
et et alma est ce que le format de
normandie est mort ou pas est-ce qu'il
faut l'élargir voilà une première
question quels ils sont à répondre dans
les semaines à venir par quoi rapport en
réponse par rapport à ce qu'a dit
aujourd'hui vladimir poutine à quoi
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre de la part
de de washington et les capitales
occidentales puisqu'il a parlé d des
capitales occidentales est ce qu'on peut
craindre une escalade gens me dire pas
seulement verbale mais de manière
physique également comment ça pourrait
se traduire sur le terrain c'est une
nouvelle guerre froide est possible non
bon guerre froide en revanche on n'a pas
le temps d'en parler c'est un terme très
très
difficile mais
byden joba eden et les occidentaux ont
fait savoir que s'il y avait eu une
intervention
russe massive en ukraine il y aurait pas
des militaires l'ukraine n'est pas
membre de l'otan elle peut pas faire
mettre en oeuvre ce fameux article 5 qui
est propre et qui qui disposent d'une
assistance non ils ont parlé de
sanctions massives comme on n'a jamais
vu la saison a fermement depuis de
nombreux jours maintenant une présumée
potentiel invasion russe de l'ukraine
non je crois que c'est bon ça ça fait
partie j'ai à dire d'une gesticulation
diplomatique
poutine l'a fait au printemps il a
obtenu le face à face avec byden ils se
sont parlés je crois qu'il faut écarter
ce genre de menaces maintenant il faut
passer dix ans la diplomatie et je
voulais dire normalement si si jo byden
tient sa parole si l'appareil américain
tient sa parole il doit faire des
propositions très rapide justement pour
définir
sous quelle forme ans il y aura ces
discussions les cesu ni les occidentaux
et l'otan ne sont pas fermes mais à
discussion simplement ils veulent seul
tenait le temps de négocier entre eux de
se concerter effectivement j'espère
qu'il y aura avant noël ou au moins
avant le nouvel an bon
il faut pas tout de suite négocier
tdlv le jour un petit peu de manière
précipitée puisqu'il ya tellement de
données ils sont en jeu mais où il faut
espérer que pour pour rétablir un
minimum de confiance qui avait
pratiquement disparu cette confiance
elle était introuvable donc il faut
baisser la tension se mettent d'accord
sur un format de discussion alors ça
serait très bien qu'une discussion il ya
pas longtemps vous avez évoqué le mois
de juin alors de la rencontre d'un jeune
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden et
ils se sont vus une nouvelle fois par
visioconférence il ya deux semaines oui
tout à fait alors bon vous savez en deux
heures on peut pas tout on peut pas tout
est allé tout discuté et les
propositions russes sont postérieurs à
l'entretien baydan poutine qui date du 7
décembre puisque c'est vendredi dernier
le cese que monsieur riabkov le vice
ministre en recevant le secrétaire
d'état adjoint américain lui a donné ces
deux textes elle est là elle a pris le
taxi héritier je vais me concerter que
mes alliés donc voyez tout ça ça va vite
on parle les textes la proposition des
deux traités on les connaît depuis lé 16
les russes ont dit on va négocier dès le
samedi 18 aujourd'hui on est le mardi 21
je crois qu'il faut laisser le temps au
temps
c'est bien on peut pas tout régler en
quatre jours je crois que la priorité et
je la sens quand même une une volonté de
négocier mais avant de négocier sous un
établir le format est ensuite lors du
jour des questions voilà est il
finalement
monsieur bah il ya déjà vous savez
qu'après la réunion ces choix vous l'at
il de même mentionner les américains et
les russes ont dit qu'ils mettraient qui
mettrait en relation leurs excès parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de problèmes il ya les
missions et moyenne portée il ya des
exercices et à 6 800 kg à il ya beaucoup
de volets alors est-ce qu'on va
globalisé où est ce qu'on va séparer
voilà on en est là
merci jeanne d'arc d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien ambassadeur et auteur du livre la
russie pour les nuls éditions first